it's great to welcome to the program
today jefferson morley who is an author
editor of the blog jfk facts and editor
of the deep states website his next book
is called scorpions dance the president
the spymaster and watergrade watergate
rather it's great to have you on
jefferson thank you
thanks for having me david so the um
presidents for some time
have uh opted not to
release the so-called jfk papers there
was initially of quite a long delay put
in place in terms of releasing them to
the public donald trump
and joe biden
have taken positions on that that have
led to significant speculation about
what may be in these files and these
papers um there are a number of what we
might colloquially call conspiracy
theories that exist around the the
murder of jfk as i'm sure you know and
uh the the issue of the files has only
has only fed that talk to us about what
do we know about these files and what
are the the reasons at least as stated
as to their being kept uh private
okay thank you david let's step back and
just look at what the law says that
it's it's a little complicated so it's
worth explaining to understand how we've
gotten to this moment yes in 1992
oliver stone released his movie jfk
which was with an a-list hollywood cast
a very smart screenplay a very
compelling piece of cinema portrayed
kennedy's assassination as the work of a
high-level conspiracy
this triggered outrage in washington
indignation
severe attacks on oliver stone which
continued to this day
um
saying he had taken liberties with
history and all of that
stone responded with a very effective
response which is if the government
isn't hiding anything why is it hiding
so much and he pointed out that in 1992
nearly 30 years after the assassination
of the president
80 percent of the government's records
on the subject were entirely classified
he put that in
in the trailer at the end of the movie
and he said if you're upset about this
you know call your congressman and so um
that resulted in a flood of mail to
capitol hill and congress actually did
the right thing they said we're going to
release all these records to quell all
this speculation and so they passed a
very strong law called the jfk records
act um it passed unanimously imagine
that david unanimously something that
would never happen in today's political
environment but pretty much everybody
across the political spectrum agreed all
jfk records should be made public and so
the law created an independent board to
go and ask government
agencies for their records the board
reviewed them and released them publicly
the agencies the cia the fbi uh
the pentagon they had the right to
request the delay of the release of
certain materials based on their
concerns about national securities
privacy and all that so
that was a very effective law and in the
1990s we got a huge batch of new records
about the jfk assassination which really
changed understanding deepened our
understanding of what exactly happened
on november 22nd 1963 um when president
kennedy was assassinated and these
records illuminated a couple of things
that were not known before just how much
the cia knew about lee harvey
propaganda operations around oswald both
before and after the assassination so we
learned a lot from those materials
after 25 years all of everything was
supposed to be made public congress
wrote in a sunset provision after 25
years
the agencies have the right to delay
release of information but they can't
postpone it forever and after 25 years
everything should be made secret i mean
made public so 1992 you go to forward
fast forward 25 years october 2017
the final
release of jfk records falls to donald
trump
trump goes on twitter and says
uh all jfk
files have been released ahead of time
okay not surprisingly that statement was
false all the jfk records were not
released and they were not released
ahead of time
when the dust cleared and we figured out
what had happened what what had happened
was mike pompeo cia director went to
trump and said we cannot possibly
release all of these records and
christopher wray from this fbi said the
same thing and so they prevailed on
trump to continue to delay the release
of this material which by law was
supposed to become public for another
four years
so
we have some idea what's in those
records um
a lot of those records have been
declassified maybe except for a word or
a paragraph so we know something about
what's in these records four years later
the decision falls to joe biden last
month
and on late on the night of october 22nd
biden the white house announced that
nothing
would be released this year
the second time that the deadline
written into the law approved
unanimously by congress for the second
time the federal agencies blew the
deadline
right and um
oh sorry we kind of lost connection with
their every second
the ball the records that remain
yeah jefferson your connection kind of
went in and out there your connection
went in and out there and so we we we
got 99 of what you said there uh let let
me sort of frame up my my next question
here um
the speculation of course is that
the full release unredacted of
everything would it would tell us the
truth about the assassination itself
whereas more measured perspectives are
well
there's
potentially stuff in these documents
related to for example operation
northwoods or other things that don't
really relate to the assassination
itself what do you believe is
still unknown so to speak
well i i think what we've learned from
from the disclosures in the 1990s is
that the official story
that some guy came out of nowhere and
shot the president for no reason that
story's false
lee harvey oswald the man accused of
doing the killing was very very well
known at the upper ranks of the cia so
in my perspective some people say and
people it's a it's a it's a plausible
argument it's a fair argument that
they're hiding all of this stuff but
there's nothing really important in
there nothing really germane to the
assassination itself right okay
that's a plausible argument but i don't
believe it for a couple of reasons one
if you look at how much was hidden
before now
the agencies lose the presumption of
innocence because they every step before
this
secrecy has hidden highly significant
information
so to say the last round of secrecy does
not involve highly significant
information of course it's possible i
haven't seen the records
but based on the past history
i don't think that that's warranted okay
the second thing is is that these
records could i'm not i
i'm not going to say they're going to
rearrange our understanding of the
assassination people have deeply felt
beliefs about the assassination and may
not change their mind no matter what the
evidence but i think that there is
evidence that will change uh
decisively clarify i guess i would put
it that way so for example what do i
think is in there i think
is evidence that shows that a certain
group of cia officers targeted lee
harvey oswald
for operational purposes before the
assassination and if that's true that
could well be part of a conspiracy to
kill the president so i think that will
will the will it show you know what
happened in dealey plaza these records
will not shed new light on what happened
in dealey plaza what they will shed new
light on is what the cia knew about this
the accused assassin and the
circumstances of the assassination
before and after kennedy was killed
that's where we see evidence of
malfeasance or misconduct and that's
what these records could decisively show
okay so let's let's explore that a
little bit less okay so
um
one very black and white story that some
tell is
the cia ran an operation
directed lee harvey oswald to
assassinate john f kennedy okay that
that's one story what you're suggesting
seems to be
it could be
that lee harvey oswald was not only
known to the cia
but was actually previously
used by the cia
in certain operations not having to do
with the assassination
maybe the cia even was aware that lee
harvey oswald maybe wanted to kill the
pres
i'm sort of just speculating here and
maybe the cia didn't stop him or
something but you're not necessarily
saying it's a directed assassination
well i haven't seen the record so no i
understand i understand yeah yeah what
what you're saying is possible
that that what they're hiding is they're
hiding incompetence sure not hiding
incriminating information right okay
i think that's possible again i doubt it
because first of all first of all
if if that was the feeling inside the
cia like oh you know we screwed up we
missed this guy we should have
you know we could have you might see
some trace of that mentality in the
records
okay
there is nothing there is no evidence to
confirm that in the available record
that that's why they are doing what they
are doing so that's one reason why i
doubt it nobody in the cia has ever said
oh we screwed up about oswald if you
look at their behavior it is much more
consistent with
this guy is part of a covert operation
that we cannot talk about and so what
i'm saying is i think there's an
undisclosed cia operation around oswald
whose purposes we don't know and whose
purpose is the cia does not want to
disclose
from there if that's true we will have a
better understanding of how to assess
the conspiracy question so you're right
i'm
i'm not
jumping to conspiratorial conclusions
because
i have not seen the
the cia has seen the red thing as true
if they wanted to exonerate themselves
if they said
you know we screwed up
right we weren't guilty of anything
negative about the president but we did
screw up in a certain way you know
they're free to say that but david when
they've blown the deadline twice
my strong impression is they do not want
to comply with the law
there's a law about the assassination of
president united states and they don't
want to comply with it so what does that
tell you that tells you i think that we
need to be skeptical about
exonatory or
you know exonerating the cia before we
see
all the evidence yeah i mean can i can
really see it both ways because even if
it is mere incompetence from everything
i know about the cia and american
intelligence agencies it is plausible to
me that even if it's incompetence and
not incriminating that they would go to
any length in order to hide that i mean
that that to me
that motive alone to me does not
necessarily put me in the same mindset
that it sounds like maybe you're in on
it
well i i i go back to what i said before
i don't see any sign of of specific
individuals in the cia having that
reaction to the story so far yeah and
certainly and certainly no cia spokesman
has come forward and said you know
that's the case so we need to see the
records to decide for exactly this point
that we're on is is you know is a more
you know negative skeptical
interpretation warranted or is there
another you know another one
that's the question that's raised by the
evidence
um last thing i wanted to ask about
there's a passage this operation
northwoods that's sort of wrapped up in
all of this my understanding is that
operation northwoods was the idea of an
operation to create false flag attacks
against the united states to justify
aggression towards cuba and that it is
an operation that was never actually
enacted from everything that i've been
able to read is my understanding
accurate and how might it relate to all
of these files
yeah so just just to rehearse very
quickly operation northwoods was a plan
approved by the pentagon in may 1963
to
design to provoke a war with cuba and
the idea was stage a spectacular attack
in the united states blame it on cuba
and then the united states would have
the justification you say
there is no evidence that operation
northwoods was ever implemented that's
true although
the the record of operation of
northwoods is is incomplete so let's say
that first of all second of all the cia
has never said that it was never
implemented the cia's in-house historian
said that on a blog it was not an
official statement of the agency that's
the second point okay the third
oh we just lost you again
sorry jefferson i hate to integration
your connection
failed on the third point tell us the
third point again
right okay okay and and the third point
is operation northwoods was approved
unanimously by the joint chiefs of staff
on may first 1963. so
my point is
the idea that the way to liberate cuba
was to stage a spectacular crime in the
united states and blame it on cuba was
very common at the upper levels of the
cia and the pentagon
was north woods ever put into practice
on november 22 no there's no record of
that but that mentality that corrupt
anti-democratic mentality was pervasive
at the upper levels of the pentagon and
the cia in november 1963 and i believe
that operation northwoods is the
template it might not have been the
official form but is the template of
what happened in dealey plaza stage a
spectacular crime and blame it on cuba
um
do you believe that uh
we'll ever have uh sort of like full
satisfaction on this where where as a
everybody's satisfied that we know what
took place no no i don't think that but
but i do think that that that big
changes in in
common
and
waves of historical revisionism 50 years
ago if you said thomas jefferson had a
relationship with his you know one of
his slaves and you know uh and had
children with her people would have said
that's a ridiculous anti-american rumor
you know 50 years later most historians
agree that
public opinion on a big historical
question can change over time and i
think no no everybody's not going to be
satisfied but i think when we get the
rest of these records we will have a
clearer understanding of what led to
president kennedy's death i do believe
that
we have been speaking with jefferson
morley his next book is scorpions dance
the president the spymaster and
watergate uh great speaking to you i
really appreciate your time
thank you david thanks for giving me the
opportunity